I have heard that increased, you know,
sinophils means I have allergies, is that true?
Possibly, yeah.
So, yes, sinophils are a type of white blood cell.
When you get your CBC done,
you want to get a CBC with differential.
Now, most clinics are never going to run a CBC
without running a differential.
I mean, a differential means you're differentiating
between the types of white blood cells that we're measuring.
So, now, I have seen, especially in the hospital setting,
where they'll, somebody goes into the emergency route
and they just run us in a simple,
you know, some simple metabolic panel.
It's like, good mistakes.
And then they charge a person's insurance, you know,
$1,000 for this $5 test.
It's absolutely ridiculous.
And you don't run a differential.
It's absolutely no sense if you're going to do a CBC
without running a differential.
So, the differential splits out the white blood cells
into, you know, it's major components.
There's, you could split it out much deeper
and do a whole lymphocyte panel.
But, it splits it out into its major components.
What's, how many lymphocytes actually?
Absolute is called the,
the numbers that they count in the slide
that they're looking at, and then percentage.
So, you typically, the differential you have
lymphocytes, neutrophils, basophils,
eosinophils, monocytes.
And then it'll give a absolute value and a percentage value.
So, if you have an increased absolute value
and an increased percentage value
of one of those things,
it gives you clues to why the white blood cell count
may be elevated.
You could even have a normal white blood cell count.
You could have an abnormal differential.
So, on these, we've discussed the differentials
on the white blood cells with neutrophils before.
Typically, if you have an elevated neutrophil,
it may be significant that you have a bacterial infection.
Typically, if you have an elevated lymphocyte,
it may be more critical
that you have a viral infection.
If you have an elevated eosinophil,
does that mean that you have an allergy?
It can be, that's one of the things that it can be.
So, food allergies, environmental allergies,
you know, a person that has really bad environmental allergies
that say pollen allergies
can have an elevated eosinophil at that time of the year.
So, that can be significant,
but also intestinal parasites can increase eosinophils.
And then people with allergic type conditions
like asthma can have an elevated eosinophil.
So, just like any of the other differential components,
it's not a perfect science.
It's like, oh, if you have this, then you have this.
You know, you have to correlate it with other things.
Let's say the person, you know,
we did a stool sample test and they have no intestinal parasites
and no symptoms of intestinal parasites,
but they, you know, they have signs and symptoms of allergies
that you might correlate it with.
That's probably what it's coming from.
And then that would certainly spark you too.
Maybe we should run a food panel
or maybe we should do this or whatever.
But even with most food sensitivities
and such, you don't see acute uprise in eosinophils
unless it's an acute condition.
And remember, you're drawing this blood
at just one specific time of the day
that you're drawing to, you know,
this pile of blood out of a person's arm.
So, it really depends on what's going on
specifically at that time with that individual.
So, it's not elevated in eosinophils.uncommon,
but it's certainly not common.
And so, you would look,
you just, it was spark you to look for the reason why.
But the biggest reasons why it would be a intestinal parasites,
food sensitivities, environmental sensitivities,
there's some sort of allergic condition going on.
Maybe even a hypersense type of mass cell response
at that particular time.
Asba, something like that,
you'd be looking at those possibilities.